WELCOME. OUR SERGEANTS ERICA AND
MATT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ASSISTANCE HERE. OKAY SO WE'RE
GOING TO WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN AS
A SUBCOMMITTEE HERE AS SOON AS
WE HAVE AN ASSEMBLY AUTHOR. BUT
LET ME BEGIN BY ANNOUNCING THOSE
BILLS THAT ARE ON CONSENT. SO IF
YOU'RE HERE FOR A BILL, IT'S ON
CONSENT. I WOULD EXPECT TO
REMAIN ON CONSENT. THEY ARE AS
FOLLOWS AB 3286 BY THE ASSEMBLY
PRIVACY AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
COMMITTEE, AB 2278 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WENDY CARILLO. AB 2287 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN AB 2687 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DIXON AB 2455,
WITH AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL AB 2835 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL AB. 1906
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIBSON AB
2628 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER. HART A
ACR 169 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
AB 295 WITH AMENDMENTS BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWENTHAL AB
THREE 196 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STEPHANIE NGUYEN, AB 1785 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PACHI KHÓ AB
2049 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER PACHECO
AB 801 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON. THAT'S WITH
AMENDMENTS AB 801 WITH
AMENDMENTS AB 2096 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS AB 1948 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RENDON AB 2373
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RENDON AB
2225 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ AB 2841 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. WALDRON WITH AMENDMENTS
AND AB 1900 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER. SO NOW LET ME ANNOUNCE
THE PRELIMINARY RULES HERE,
WHICH WE WILL FOLLOW FOR ALL
MATTERS, ALL BILLS THERE WILL BE
PERMITTED TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT AND TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION, FOR THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
IN OPPOSITION AND IN OPPOSITION.
EACH OF THEM WILL BE AFFORDED
TWO MINUTES EACH FOR A TOTAL OF
FOUR MINUTES. AFTER FOR THE TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES, IF THERE ARE
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT, TESTIFY WILL TAKE,
OTHERS WHO ARE IN SUPPORT WHO
ARE HERE AND THOSE THOSE
INDIVIDUALS SHOULD APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE, GIVE US THEIR NAME,
THEIR AFFILIATION AND THEIR
POSITION. IN OTHER WORDS, THEIR
NAME. IF THEY'RE AFFILIATED WITH
AN ORGANIZATION AND THEIR
POSITION, EITHER SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE OR WHAT HAVE YOU ON THE
BILL, WE'LL FOLLOW THE EXACT
SAME PROTOCOL FOR THOSE IN
OPPOSITION. TWO WITNESSES, TWO
MINUTES EACH, AND THEN WE'LL
TAKE TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION BY
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE AND
GIVING US YOUR NAME, YOUR
AFFILIATION, AND YOUR POSITION.
ALL RIGHT. SO WE HAVE ONCE
AGAIN, THE REPUBLICANS HAVE
OUTDONE THE DEMOCRATS. THEY
THERE ARE 50% OF THE REPUBLICANS
ARE HERE. AND ONLY, PROBABLY
YES, ONLY ONLY ABOUT 18% OF THE
DEMOCRATS. SO WE WOULD WELCOME
AUTHORS. THERE'S IF YOU SHOW UP,
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO JUST WALK
RIGHT UP TO THE MICROPHONE AND
BEGIN PRESENTATION. SO IF YOU
ARE A ASSEMBLY MEMBER, CERVANTES
OR ASSEMBLY MEMBER, FRIEDMAN OR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, GABRIEL OR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA, THAT'S
IT. YOU, YOU WOULD BE IN LUCK IF
YOU SHOWED UP.
SOME MEMBER. CERVANTES WE ARE A
SUBCOMMITTEE. BUT I WELCOME YOUR
PRESENTATION ON. ON AB 1899.
FANTASTIC. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MR. CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS,
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
AB 1899, WHICH WILL UPDATE THE
PROSPECTIVE JURORS
IDENTIFICATION PROCESS AS WELL
AS THE JURY SELECTION PROCESS.
EXISTING LAW ALLOWS FOR A JURY
COMMISSIONER TO REQUIRE A PERSON
TO COMPLETE A QUESTIONNAIRE THAT
ASKS QUESTIONS RELATED TO
IDENTIFICATION, THÀNH,
QUALIFICATION, AND ABILITY TO
SERVE AS A PROSPECTIVE JUROR.
THE FIRST TYPE OF JURY
QUESTIONNAIRE FORM IS MEANT TO
OBTAIN IDENTIFICATION
QUALIFICATIONS, AND ABILITY TO
SERVE. THE SECOND TYPE IS MEANT
FOR ASSISTING IN THE JURY
SELECTION PROCESS OR TO
DETERMINE IF THE SELECTION OF
THE POPULATION IS REPRESENTATIVE
. THIS OCCURS ONCE THE
PROSPECTIVE JURORS PLACED ON A
JURY PANEL. THIS MEANS THAT THE
PROSPECTIVE JURORS ANSWERS ON
THE QUESTIONNAIRE FOR ASSISTING
IN JURY SELECTION ARE GIVEN
UNDER PENALTY OF PERJURY, WHILE
THE JURY SELECTION PROCESS
VARIES CONSIDERABLY ACROSS
JURISDICTIONS, USUALLY
QUESTIONING IS DONE BY A JUDGE
OR A COUNCIL, OR A TEMPLATE
JUROR QUESTIONNAIRE THAT USES
INCLUSIVE LANGUAGE FOR GENDER
NON-CONFORMING AND NON-BINARY
INDIVIDUALS MAY ALLEVIATE THE
PRESSURES OF MISIDENTIFIED
NATION AS THEY FULFILL ONE OF
THEIR OBLIGATIONS AS CITIZENS OF
THE UNITED STATES. WE ALL KNOW
THAT TRADITIONAL APPROACHES
LIMIT THE INCLUSION OF THE LGBTQ
PLUS COMMUNITY AND CAN
CONTRIBUTE TO THE ERASURE OF
IDENTITY THAT MAY CAUSE HARM TO
THESE MARGINALIZED GROUPS, AS WE
ARE ALSO AWARE, THE LGBTQ PLUS
COMMUNITY HAS OFTEN BEEN
OTHERED, AND THIS BILL SEEKS TO
CHANGE THAT FOR MANY IN
CALIFORNIA BY ACKNOWLEDGMENT AND
AFFIRMATION OF DIVERSE GENDER
IDENTITIES MAY REDUCE THE
POTENTIAL FOR DISCOMFORT AND
ALIENATION DURING THE JURY
SELECTION PROCESS. ACCORDING TO
THE UNITED STATES CENSUS BUREAU,
IT IS ESTIMATED THAT THERE ARE
2.7 MILLION LGBTQ PLUS PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA. INDIVIDUALS WHO
EXPERIENCE MISGENDERING OFTEN
EXPERIENCE PSYCHOLOGICAL
DISTRESS AND DEPRESSION. AB 1899
WILL REQUIRE THE SUPERIOR COURTS
TO ASK FOR THEIR PRONOUNS IN AN
OPEN ENDED FORMAT, AND PROHIBIT
THE USE OF GENDERED SALUTATIONS.
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE A LEVEL
OF CONSISTENCY ACROSS OUR ENTIRE
STATE BY REQUIRING THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL TO PUBLISH A TEMPLATE
JUROR QUESTIONNAIRE THAT WILL BE
INCLUSIVE OF THE LGBTQ PLUS
COMMUNITY. FINALLY, THIS BILL
WILL UPDATE THE MAXIMUMS OF
JURISPRUDENCE, WHICH WERE
ENACTED IN 1872 TO USE GENDER
NEUTRAL TERMS. WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT? NO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT. IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF AB 1899, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE SEEING
NO ONE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
LET'S TURN NOW TO THE OPPOSITION
. IF YOU'RE OPPOSED TO AB 1899,
PLEASE COME FORWARD. DAVID
BULLOCK OF THE SFE ALLIANCE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU AUNTIE.
THANK YOU. OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO ONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION. LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE. COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
QUESTIONS SENATOR LAIRD, I JUST
I KNOW THERE'S NO QUORUM. I
THINK THIS IS A GOOD BILL, AND
I'LL BE HAPPY TO MOVE IT WHEN WE
GET A QUORUM. OKAY. AND I WAS
THERE IN 1872. THEY SHOULDN'T.
THEY SHOULD HAVE DONE THAT. YOU
KNOW, AND I REMEMBER THAT,
SENATOR LAIRD. SO ALL RIGHT,
SEEING NO QUESTIONS, NO
COMMENTS. THEN SOME OF THE
MEMBERS, CERVANTES. WHEN WE HAVE
A QUORUM, SENATOR LAIRD HAS
PROMISED TO MOVE THE BILL AND
WE'LL BRING IT FORWARD, SO. ALL
RIGHT, THANK YOU SO MUCH. OKAY
THANK YOU. COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OH, I'M SORRY. THANK YOU, MR.
VICE CHAIR. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. WELL CERTAINLY LOOK FORWARD
TO JUST MAKING SURE THAT WE
PROVIDE A MORE WELCOMING AND
SAFE SPACE FOR ALL OF THOSE WHO
REFLECT CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. I APPRECIATE AND I VOTE
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT, WE'RE NOW
AWAITING OTHER AUTHORS, AND WE
AIM TO SERVE HERE IN SENATE
JUDICIARY. IF YOU ARRIVE, YOU
WILL IMMEDIATELY BE ABLE TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AND
PRESENT YOUR BILL. MR. CHAIR,
THIS MORNING.
SO WE'RE JUST LACKING TWO
MEMBERS TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM
HERE, SO IF YOU'RE WITHIN
EARSHOT AND YOU'RE SERVING ON
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE, IT
WOULD BE WONDERFUL IF YOU
PRESENTED YOURSELF.
HELLO. I BEG YOUR PARDON. WE
WERE IN ANOTHER COMMITTEE FOR
THIS. WELL, WE ARE. WE AIM TO
AIM TO PLEASE HERE. SO WHEN YOU
COME IN, YOU GET RIGHT UP TO THE
MICROPHONE, I LIKE IT. I'LL COME
BACK MORE OFTEN. ALL RIGHT, ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. SO,
YES. LET'S SEE. FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIX, AB 28. OH ONE. WHERE?
SUBCOMMITTEE. GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND I
WANTED TO THANK YOU AND YOUR
STAFF FOR ALL OF YOUR HARD WORK
ON THIS BILL. THIS BILL COMES
OUT OF AN EXPERIENCE FROM ONE OF
OUR STAFF MEMBERS. AND WE HAVE
HEARD SINCE WE INTRODUCED THIS
BILL OF MANY OTHER PEOPLE THAT
WE KNOW WHO HAVE HAD SIMILAR
EXPERIENCES OF LANDLORDS TAKING,
KEEPING THEIR SECURITY DEPOSIT
WHEN THERE WASN'T REALLY A
REASON FOR THAT, AND THEN
FEELING THAT THEY REALLY HAD NO
RECOURSE. AND WE WITH THIS BILL,
ARE TRYING TO NOT SET ANY NEW
LAW IN TERMS OF WHAT YOU CAN
KEEP A SECURITY DEPOSIT FOR, BUT
JUST GIVE GREATER CLARITY TO
LANDLORDS AND TENANTS ABOUT
ABOUT THE CONDITIONS THAT
CURRENT LAW ALREADY SETS FOR
THAT AND HOW YOU WOULD GO ABOUT
BY PROVING THAT. SO UNDER
CURRENT LAW, A LANDLORD CAN ONLY
CLAIM A SECURITY DEPOSIT WHOSE
AMOUNTS ARE REASONABLY NECESSARY
FOR THE REPAIR OF DAMAGE TO THE
PREMISES, EXCLUSIVE OF ORDINARY
WEAR AND TEAR. THAT'S ALREADY IN
THE LAW TO RETURN THAT UNIT TO
THE SAME LEVEL OF CLEANLINESS.
IT WAS AT THE INCEPTION OF THE
TENANCY. IF A LANDLORD WITHHOLDS
ALL OR PART OF A SECURITY
DEPOSIT WITHOUT A VALID REASON,
THIS IS KNOWN AS BAD FAITH
RETENTION. AND UNFORTUNATELY, WE
HAVE HEARD OF CASES WHERE
LANDLORDS ARE JUST ROUTINELY
KEEPING PEOPLE SECURITY DEPOSIT
WITHOUT THERE BEING DAMAGE, AND
MANY TIMES TENANTS WILL JUST
GIVE UP RATHER THAN TRY TO FIGHT
. AND A LOT OF TIMES THEY DON'T
KNOW HOW TO DO THAT. AND WITHOUT
HAVING THAT SECURITY DEPOSIT
BACK, A LOT OF TIMES TENANTS
JUST CAN'T PUT A SECURITY
DEPOSIT DOWN ON THEIR NEXT UNIT.
THIS IS A REAL PROBLEM AND IT'S
NOT FAIR. AB 2801 HELPS WITH
GIVING SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES A LITTLE
EXTRA PROTECTIONS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY UNDERSTAND THE LAW.
THE BILL REQUIRES A LANDLORD TO
JUSTIFY THROUGH BEFORE AND AFTER
PICTURES WHY ANY FUNDS FROM THE
SECURITY DEPOSIT WERE WITHHELD,
AND IT LIMITS THE AMOUNT FOR
MATERIALS AND SUPPLIES DEDUCTED
TO THOSE THAT ARE REALLY
REASONABLY NECESSARY TO RETURN
THE UNIT BACK TO THE CONDITION
IT WAS NOT TO UPGRADE THE UNIT
FOR THE NEXT TENANT, NOT BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO SPEND A LOT OF
MONEY ON SOMETHING FANCY, BUT TO
BRING IT BACK. AS THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL POINTED OUT IN A RECENT
SETTLEMENT WITH A PREDATORY
LANDLORD, FOR MANY RENTERS,
ESPECIALLY THOSE FROM LOWER
INCOME BACKGROUNDS, AFFORDING A
SECURITY DEPOSIT ENTAILS A GREAT
DEAL OF SACRIFICE. I WANT TO
THANK THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION AGAIN FOR WORKING
DILIGENTLY WITH US ON THIS BILL
TO FIND LANGUAGE THAT STRIKES A
BALANCE FOR BOTH THE LANDLORD
AND THE TENANT, FOR ENSURING
THAT THE SECURITY DEPOSITS
DEDUCTIONS APPLY TO WHAT
EXISTING LAW INTENDED. AND TO BE
CLEAR, CAA IS NEUTRAL. I BELIEVE
ON THE BILL BECAUSE WE HAVE
WORKED VERY CLOSELY WITH THEM.
TESTIFYING AND SUPPORT THIS
AFTERNOON IS KATE ROGERS,
DIRECTOR OF POLICY FOR GEN-UP,
AND ALEXANDRA ROMO, A MEMBER OF
POWER CALIFORNIA ACTION. AND
WITH THAT, I WOULD REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. OKAY. GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE. MY NAME IS
KATE ROGERS, AND I'M A C  CHIEF
OF POLICY FOR GENERATION UP. AND
I'M HERE TODAY TO REPRESENT THE
STUDENT HOMES COALITION. WE'RE
MADE UP OF SEVERAL HIGHER ED
GROUPS ACROSS THE STATE,
INCLUDING UTSA, OUR TIME TO ACT
AND Y AND OF COURSE, CHEN UP, AS
WELL AS 24 CAMPUS BASED
AFFILIATES THAT ARE ADVOCATING
FOR A FAIR HOUSING POLICIES AT
UC'S COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
CSU'S. SO THIS PAST YEAR WAS MY
FIRST YEAR LIVING OFF CAMPUS.
I'M A CURRENT JUNIOR AT UCLA,
AND LIKE MANY CAMPUSES IN
CALIFORNIA, UCLA IS REALLY JUST
NOT AN AFFORDABLE AREA. SO WHEN
MY ROOMMATES AND I FINALLY FOUND
A PLACE, WE REALLY STRUGGLED TO
COME UP WITH THE MONEY FOR OUR
DEPOSITS. THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS,
SO WE REALLY WE NEED THIS MONEY
BACK WHEN WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
OUT. SO YOU CAN IMAGINE THAT I
WAS REALLY DISHEARTENED WHEN I
HEARD FROM FORMER TENANTS IN MY
BUILDING AND OTHER PEOPLE IN THE
AREA THAT WE STOOD, BASICALLY NO
CHANCE OF GETTING ANY OF IT BACK
, ANY WEAR AND TEAR, INCLUDING
JUST ORDINARY DAMAGE, WOULD
RESULT IN US LIKE LOSING HUGE
AMOUNTS OF MONEY OFF OF OUR
DEPOSIT. AND AS I WOULD COME TO
LEARN AND ANY WESTWOOD RENTER
WOULD TELL YOU, THIS IS JUST NOT
UNIQUE TO MY LANDLORD AND Ã
PROPERTY MANAGERS KNOW THAT
STUDENTS HAVE BASICALLY NO
CHOICE BUT TO LIVE WITHIN A VERY
LIMITED RADIUS OF OUR CAMPUS,
AND THAT MAKES IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR
US TO ESCAPE UNFAIR PRACTICES OR
JUST ASTRONOMICALLY HIGH RENTS,
SO TO MAKE MATTERS WORSE, THEY
ALSO KNOW THAT, LIKE MOST OF US,
LIKE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN
SAID, DON'T REALLY HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO CHALLENGE ANY
DEDUCTIONS IN SMALL CLAIMS COURT
, SO FOR THEM, IT MIGHT MEAN AN
EXTRA MONTH OR TWO OF, YOU KNOW,
PROFIT, IN TERMS OF THE RENT.
BUT FOR US, THAT'S OUR ABILITY
TO AFFORD TO MOVE, TO PAY OUR
BILLS AND TO PUT FOOD ON OUR
TABLES. SO AB 2801 IS A TOP
PRIORITY FOR THE STUDENT HOMES
COALITION, BECAUSE IT'S A TOP
PRIORITY FOR THE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS THAT WE
REPRESENT. SO BY INSTITUTING
STRICTER REQUIREMENTS ON WHEN
AND HOW LANDLORDS CAN MAKE
CLAIMS ON A TENANT'S SECURITY
DEPOSIT. AB 2801 WILL PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
TENANTS AND PROMOTE EQUAL ACCESS
TO HOUSING. SO, ON BEHALF OF
CHEN UP UCSB, WHY I OUGHTA AND
THE STUDENT HOMES COALITION
AFFILIATES, I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE QUICK
QUESTION BEFORE WE TURN THE NEXT
SPEAKER, WHEN I LIVED ON
GLENROCK A FEW YEARS AGO, RENTS
WERE $83 A MONTH. HAVE THEY GONE
UP? THEY CERTAINLY HAVE, YES.
I'M JUST CURIOUS. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. WHOLE QUESTION.
RIGHT. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU,
HELLO. GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE.
MY NAME IS. I'M SORRY TO
INTERRUPT, BUT LET'S FORM A
QUORUM HERE BECAUSE I KNOW
THERE'S OTHER COMMITTEES THAT
ARE THAT ARE ALSO MEETING. SO,
MADAM SECRETARY, IF YOU CALL THE
ROLL FOR PURPOSES OF
ESTABLISHING A QUORUM, BERG
HERE, UMMC HERE, WILK PRESENT.
WILK PRESENT. ALAN ASHBY HERE.
ASHBY. HERE. CABALLERO.
CABALLERO. HERE DURAZO. DURAZO
HERE. LAIRD. LAYERED HERE. NILO.
ROTH. STERN WAHAB. ALLEN. ALLEN.
HERE YOU HAVE A QUORUM. WE HAVE
A QUORUM. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. GO
AHEAD. OF COURSE, GOOD OR GOOD
AFTERNOON, EVERYONE. MY NAME IS
ALEJANDRO ROMO. I'M A MEMBER OF
POWER CALIFORNIA ACTION HERE
TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF 2801
AB, 2801, I WAS BORN IN
AGUASCALIENTES, MEXICO. I MOVED
TO LOS ANGELES WHEN I WAS ONE
YEAR OLD. I CURRENTLY LIVE IN
CULVER CITY AND AM A RISING
SENIOR AT CALIFORNIA STATE, LONG
BEACH, WHICH TURMBERG REPRESENTS
AB 2801 IS SO IMPORTANT FOR
YOUNG CALIFORNIAN RENTERS. AT
THE END OF 2023, MY FRIEND
REBECCA EXPERIENCED THE
FRUSTRATION OF UNFAIR SECURITY
DEPOSIT DEDUCTIONS BEFORE MOVING
OUT OF HER APARTMENT, SHE MET
WITH MANAGEMENT FOR AN
INSPECTION. SHE EMPTIED OUT THE
APARTMENT AS MUCH AS SHE COULD
TO ENSURE THE MOST ACCURATE
INSPECTION. MANAGEMENT ASSURED
HER THAT AS THAT THEY SAW NO
DAMAGES AND AS LONG AS SHE
CLEANED THE APARTMENT, SHE WOULD
RECEIVE HER FULL DEPOSIT, EVEN
THOUGH SHE LEFT THE APARTMENT
CLEANER THAN WHEN SHE FIRST
MOVED IN, SHE ONLY RECEIVED 54%
OF HER OF HER DEPOSIT BACK 450
AND $30 WAS DEDUCTED FOR CARPET
CLEANING, PROFESSIONAL CLEANING,
AND LABOR. IF AB 2801 EXISTED,
SHE WOULD HAVE RECEIVED HER FULL
DEPOSIT BACK BECAUSE HER
BELONGINGS WERE REMOVED FOR
INSPECTION AND NO REPAIRS OR
CLEANINGS WERE LISTED IN THE
ITEMIZED STATEMENT. DURING THE
INSPECTION, WE DESERVE TO HAVE
OUR SECURITY DEPOSITS RETURNED
TO US WHEN WE MOVE OUT OF AN
APARTMENT, AS LONG AS WE KEEP IT
IN GOOD SHAPE, MANY RENTERS
DEPEND ON THE RETURN OF THEIR
SECURITY DEPOSIT TO BE ABLE TO
AFFORD TO MOVE TO ANOTHER
APARTMENT. THAT'S WHY I SUPPORT
AB 2801 WITH THESE ADDITIONAL
PROTECTIONS, RENTERS CAN AVOID
UNDUE FINANCIAL BURDENS. GETTING
BACK THEIR SECURITY DEPOSIT.
SECURITY DEPOSITS SHOULD SERVE
THEIR INTENDED PURPOSE TO
PROTECT LANDLORDS FROM DAMAGES,
NOT TO HAVE RENTERS SUBSIDIZE
UPGRADES. AB 2801 IS LEVELING
THE PLAYING FIELD AND CREATING
TRANSPARENCY FOR RENTERS AND
LANDLORDS ALIKE IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. ALRIGHTY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. GIVE US YOUR NAME,
YOUR POSITION, YOUR AFFILIATION.
SEEING OH GO AHEAD. NHIÀU TH¤U,
ON BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2801 SEEING NO ONE
ELSE APPROACHED THE MICROPHONE.
IF YOU'RE OPPOSED AB 2801 PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
CLOSURES. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, KAREEM DRISSI, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS, HERE
TODAY WITH AN OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON AB 2801 AB
2801 IMPOSES SEVERAL NEW
REQUIREMENTS ON SMALL HOUSING
PROVIDERS. WE ONLY TAKE
EXCEPTION TO ONE CHANGE THAT IS
BEING MADE BY THE BILL FOR THE
DAMAGE DONE TO THE UNIT BY A
TENANT. EXISTING LAW PROVIDES
THAT A HOUSING PROVIDER MAY
CLAIM OF THE SECURITY DEPOSIT
ONLY THOSE AMOUNTS AS ARE
REASONABLY NECESSARY. AB 2801
CHANGES EXISTING LAW BY
EXPLICITLY SPECIFYING THAT
REPAIRS MADE BY A CONTRACTOR TO
FIX DAMAGE DONE TO THE UNIT BY A
TENANT SHALL BE LIMITED TO A
REASONABLE COST AMOUNT. SMALL
HOUSING PROVIDERS DON'T CONTROL
CONTRACTOR PRICING, AND THIS NEW
LANGUAGE EFFECTIVELY LIMITS A
SMALL HOUSING PROVIDERS ABILITY
TO HAVE REPAIRS MADE PROPERLY.
THIS NEW LANGUAGE, REGARDING
WORK PERFORMED BY A CONTRACTOR
WILL CREATE CONFUSION IN THE
MARKETPLACE FOR BOTH SMALL
HOUSING PROVIDERS AND TENANTS,
AND IN TURN WILL LEAD TO
INCREASED LITIGATION UNTIL SUCH
TIME AS THE BILL IS AMENDED TO
REMOVE THIS LANGUAGE, WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A NO VOTE
ON AB 2801. AND LASTLY, I WOULD
JUST RESPECTFULLY NOTE THAT
REPAIRS THAT ARE REASONABLY
NECESSARY, WHICH IS EXISTING
STATUTE, IS QUITE DIFFERENT THAN
REPAIRS COSTING A REASONABLE
AMOUNT. AND SO WE DO LOOK
FORWARD TO, CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR AND HOPEFULLY
THIS LANGUAGE WILL BE REMOVED.
BUT AT THIS TIME WE DO ASK FOR A
NO VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION TO AB 2801,
SEEING NO ONE ELSE APPROACHED
THE MICROPHONE. LET'S BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS SEEING NO
QUESTIONS, SENATOR RUSSO HAS
MOVED THE BILL. SENATOR
CABALLERO IS A QUESTION. I JUST
HAVE A QUESTION IN REGARDS TO
THE REQUEST BY THE REALTORS.
HAVE YOU HAD THAT, ISSUE RAISED
BEFORE? AND IF YOU DID, WHAT WAS
YOUR THINKING IN TERMS OF THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN REASONABLY
NECESSARY AND REASONABLE COST
AMOUNT? YEAH. SO NECESSARY.
REASONABLY NECESSARY REFERS TO
THE NEED FOR THE REPAIR, WHICH A
LOT OF PEOPLE WOULD AGREE TO.
BUT IT'S NOT REASONABLE IF
SOMEBODY IS GETTING PRICE GOUGED
OR IF THEY ARE BEING FORCED TO
UPGRADE THE APARTMENT. AND THIS
ACTUALLY CAME OUT OF MY STAFFERS
EXPERIENCE, WHERE THEY CLAIMED
THAT THERE WAS DAMAGE TO A
WINDOW BLIND AND HE COULD HAVE
GONE TO HOME DEPOT. HE LOOKED IT
UP THE SAME BLIND WAS ABOUT
$100, AND THEY WANTED TO BILL
HIM $900. SO THAT'S WHY WE CAME
UP WITH THE STANDARD. IT
SHOULDN'T BE THAT THE SECURITY
DEPOSITS USED AS A PIGGY BANK TO
UPGRADE AN APARTMENT AND WE HAVE
TO HAVE SOME GUARDRAILS.
OTHERWISE A CONTRACTOR COULD
SAY, WELL, WHAT'S THE SECURITY
DEPOSIT FOR $300? OKAY, THE
REPAIR COSTS $4,000 THERE. YOU
KNOW, WE NEED TO HAVE. AND THE
LANGUAGE IS ALREADY IN THE LAW
IN TERMS OF REASONABLE. SO WE
WERE, YOU KNOW, TRYING TO AVOID
YOU KNOW, WHAT WE'RE HEARING
FROM MANY PEOPLE IS A IS A
COMMON PROBLEM. AND WE'RE
WILLING TO KEEP WORKING WITH
THEM. OF COURSE. OKAY. THANK YOU
I APPRECIATE THAT. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. SENATOR RUSSO HAS
MOVED THE BILL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SENATOR MEMBER FRIEDMAN,
WORKING WITH US ON THIS. I KNOW
WE TRIED TO WORK WITH SOME OF
THE STAKEHOLDERS IN TERMS OF THE
TIMING OF PHOTOGRAPHS
DEMONSTRATING REPAIRS. WE NEVER
QUITE GOT THERE, AND WHETHER OR
NOT THE TENANT NEED REQUEST OR
NOT REQUEST OR WHETHER IT'S
AUTOMATIC. AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
YOU ARE AMENABLE TO CONTINUING
TO WORK ON THAT ISSUE, IT WAS MY
MIND THAT THAT IF THERE WAS NO
REQUEST, NO NEED, THAT THAT WAS
JUST AN UNDUE BURDEN. BUT BUT WE
NEVER CAME QUITE TO ANY SORT OF
UNDERSTANDING. BUT I'M GRATEFUL
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THAT ISSUE. OF COURSE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
RECOMMENDATION ON THE BILL. AND
I WILL JUST POINT OUT THAT IF
THERE'S NOT NO CLAIM ON THE
SECURITY DEPOSIT, NOBODY HAS TO
GIVE PHOTOS, BUT WE DO THINK
THAT, YOU KNOW, FOR THESE THESE
KIDS, REALLY A LOT OF THEM,
THESE STUDENTS, PARTICULARLY,
IT'S SO EASY TO GIVE A DIGITAL
PHOTOGRAPH THESE DAYS THAT IF
YOU'RE GOING TO SAY, HEY,
THERE'S $400 OF DAMAGE TO
SOMETHING, GIVE THEM A PHOTO SO
THEY CAN SEE WHAT IT IS.
APPARENTLY, KODAK DOESN'T
DEVELOP QUITE AS QUICKLY AS IT
USED TO, BUT IN ANY EVENT, SO
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. SENATOR
RUSSO HAS MOVED THE BILL, WE'D
LIKE TO CLOSE JUST I APPRECIATE
AND I VOTE WE SEE THAT THERE IS
A, YOU KNOW, DEFINITELY A NEED
HERE. WE'RE NOT TRYING TO CREATE
NEW LAW. WE'RE JUST TRYING TO
MAKE EVERYBODY UNDERSTAND THE
PARAMETERS ON THE EXISTING LAW,
BOTH FOR THE BENEFIT OF THE
TENANTS AND THE LANDLORDS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT, MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX AB
2801. THE MOTION IS Dð. PASS
UMMC A UMMER I WILK NÓ WILK NÓ
ALLEN. ALLEN I ASHBY. ASHBY I
CABALLERO. CABALLERO I DURAZZO.
GROSSO I LAIRD. LAIRD I NILO.
ROTH. STERN. WAHAB THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. 6 TO 1. SIX ONE.
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL. ALL
RIGHT. I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL HERE. I ALSO SEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA HERE. SO
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. WELL YOU KNOW WHAT THE
OUR PRACTICE HAS BEEN TAKING
THE, CHAIR, BUT BUT I SEE THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA IS BEING
RIGHT. QUITE RIGHT. RIGHT. QUITE
ACCOMMODATING. SO ALL RIGHT,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL AB 2505.
PHYLUM NUMBER EIGHT, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, AND THANK YOU TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KHALIL FOR YOUR
GRACIOUSNESS. AND I ALSO WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR THOUGHTFUL
ASSISTANCE ON THIS MEASURE. AND
JUST START OFF BY SAYING WE'RE
HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. I AM PLEASED TODAY
TO PRESENT AB 2505, WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE ATTORNEYS IN CALIFORNIA
TO REPORT WHETHER THEY PROVIDED
PRO BONO LEGAL SERVICES IN THE
PRIOR YEAR. PRO BONO IS A
POWERFUL TOOL TO ACHIEVE
JUSTICE, PARTICULARLY FOR LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS. AND
UNFORTUNATELY, CALIFORNIA HAS
FALLEN BEHIND OTHER STATES IN
EXPANDING ACCESS TO JUSTICE AND
OUR LEGAL AID PROVIDERS HERE IN
THE STATE ARE BOTH OVERBURDENED
AND UNDERUTILIZED. OTHER STATES
HAVE ALREADY ESTABLISHED PRO
BONO REQUIREMENTS FOR REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR PRO BONO. IN
FACT, FLORIDA WAS THE FIRST
STATE TO IMPLEMENT A PRO BONO
REPORTING REQUIREMENT IN 1993,
AND SINCE THEN, ILLINOIS,
INDIANA, MARYLAND, MINNESOTA,
MISSISSIPPI, NEVADA, NEW YORK,
AND NUMEROUS OTHER STATES HAVE
JOINED THEM. THE THIS REPORTING
THAT WE ARE PROPOSING TODAY WILL
BE CONFIDENTIAL, WITH NO PENALTY
FOR FAILING TO REPORT OR FOR
REPORTING ZERO HOURS, BUT THE
DATA COLLECTED WILL BE PROVIDED
TO THE STATE BAR AND THE ACCESS
TO JUSTICE COMMISSION AND LEGAL
AID PROVIDERS, WHICH WILL BE
VERY HELPFUL FOR THEM AS THEY
DESIGN AND TAILOR BETTER POLICY
SOLUTIONS TO DELIVER ACCESS TO
JUSTICE TO COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE STATE. THE PROPOSED RULE HAS
BEEN DEVELOPED IN CLOSE
COOPERATION WITH THE STATE BAR,
AND IS SUPPORTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA ACCESS TO JUSTICE
COMMISSION, THE LEGAL AID
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA, AND
NUMEROUS LEGAL SERVICE
NONPROFITS UP AND DOWN THE
STATE. IT HAS NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION WITH ME HERE TODAY, I
HAVE JENNY GÓMEZ HADDAD, THE PRO
BONO MANAGER AT LEGAL SERVICES
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA, AND LORI
KLEIN, THE LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
AT THE LEGAL AID ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA, TO SPEAK MORE ABOUT
THE MEASURE. THANK YOU. AND I'D
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. GO AHEAD. FLOOR
IS YOURS. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NAME IS LAUREN KLEIN, AND I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF ADVOCACY AT THE
LEGAL AID ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. AND WE ARE SPONSORS
OF AB 2505. MY ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTS THE NETWORK OF STATE
FUNDED NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
THAT PROVIDE FREE CIVIL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE TO LOW INCOME PEOPLE
AND COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
DESPITE THE AMAZING WORK DONE BY
LEGAL AID, THERE REMAINS A
STAGGERING AMOUNT OF UNMET NEED.
FOR THAT REASON, WE RELY ON PRO
BONO ATTORNEYS TO HELP US MEET
THE NEEDS OF OUR CLIENT
COMMUNITIES. THIS BILL WILL
SUPPORT THE LEGAL AID COMMUNITY
IN CLOSING THE JUSTICE GAP IN A
COUPLE OF IMPORTANT WAYS. FIRST,
IT WILL INCREASE PRO BONO
VOLUNTEERISM. WHILE THIS BILL
DOES NOT MAKE PRO BONO SERVICE
MANDATORY, AS THAT WOULD BE
UNFAIR TO ATTORNEYS AND CLIENTS
ALIKE BY REQUIRING ATTORNEYS TO
REPORT THEIR PRO BONO TIME, IT
WILL RAISE THEIR AWARENESS AND
REMIND THEM OF HOW MUCH WORK
THEY'VE ACTUALLY DONE. THIS WILL
MOTIVATE LAWYERS WHO GENUINELY
ASPIRE TO DO PRO BONO WORK. BUT
MAY HAVE FALLEN OUT OF THE
HABIT. SECOND, IT WILL GIVE
LEGAL AID DATA THAT WE CAN USE
TO IMPROVE THE PRO BONO
ECOSYSTEM. CURRENTLY, WE HAVE NO
WAY OF KNOWING HOW MANY OR WHICH
ATTORNEYS DO PRO BONO OR HOW
MUCH. WITH STATE WIDE DATA, WE
CAN UNDERSTAND THE DEMOGRAPHICS
OF PRO BONO. DO MORE WOMEN DO
PRO BONO WORK THAN MEN? DO
ATTORNEYS DO MORE PRO BONO WORK?
AT THE BEGINNING OF THEIR CAREER
OR THE END OF THEIR CAREER? DO
ATTORNEYS IN ONE REGION OF THE
STATE DO MORE PRO BONO WORK THAN
IN ANOTHER? SO HAVING THIS DATA
WILL ALLOW US TO HONE OUR
OUTREACH STRATEGIES AND TO
DESIGN BETTER PRO BONO SERVICE
DELIVERY SYSTEMS. WE KNOW THAT
NOT EVERYONE CAN DO PRO BONO
WORK, BUT WITH DATA, WE CAN
UNDERSTAND THE BARRIERS THAT
EXIST AND HOW WE COULD MITIGATE
OR OVERCOME THEM. THIS BILL
PROVIDES A SIMPLE WAY TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO CIVIL LEGAL SERVICES
AND WILL PLAY AN IMPORTANT ROLE
IN CLOSING THE JUSTICE GAP IN
CALIFORNIA. WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT WITNESS. CHAIR
UMBERG AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS JENNY
GÓMEZ HADDAD, AND I'M A PROMO
PRO BONO MANAGER AT LEGAL
SERVICES OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
ON BEHALF OF LESNIK, I SUPPORT
AB 2505 AS A PRACTICING LEGAL
AID ATTORNEY FOR MORE THAN A
DECADE. I KNOW FIRSTHAND THAT
LEGAL AID PROVIDERS ARE
OVERBURDENED. WE ARE ONLY ABLE
TO HELP A FRACTION OF
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES WHO
NEED LEGAL HELP. WE RELY ON PRO
BONO ATTORNEYS TO HELP US MEET
THE NEEDS OF OUR CLIENT
COMMUNITIES. I WILL NEVER FORGET
THE CRUCIAL ROLE PRO BONO
ATTORNEYS PLAYED IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THE DEVASTATING
PARADISE CAMPFIRE LOCATED IN OUR
SERVICE AREA. WHILE STAFF FROM
ALL EIGHT OF OUR OFFICES WORKED
OVERTIME TO ASSIST SURVIVORS, IT
SIMPLY WAS NOT ENOUGH. PRO BONO
ATTORNEYS JUMPED INTO ACTION,
PROVIDING KNOW YOUR RIGHTS
PRESENTATIONS, ATTENDING CLINICS
AND TAKING ON LIMITED AND FULL
SCOPE CASES WHERE LESNIK DID NOT
HAVE THE CAPACITY OR EXPERTISE.
WE HOPE THAT THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENT WILL PRODUCE A DATA
HIGHLIGHTING PRO BONO GAPS AND
OPPORTUNITIES IN AN EFFORT TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO JUSTICE FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS. FOR EXAMPLE,
MANY OF CALIFORNIA'S PRACTICING
ATTORNEYS ARE CONCENTRATED IN
THE STATE'S URBAN CENTERS. YET
WE AT LESNIK HAVE OFFICES IN OUR
FAR NORTH SERVICE AREA, WHERE
ONLY 2 OR 3 LEGAL AID ATTORNEYS
REPRESENT INDIGENT CLIENTS IN
MULTIPLE COUNTIES. IF A PRO BONO
ATTORNEY SO CHOOSES, THEY CAN
MAKE A WONDERFUL AND NECESSARY
DIFFERENCE ACROSS THE STATE AND
ESPECIALLY IN HIGH NEED LEGAL
AID REGIONS LIKE MINE. I
APPRECIATE THAT THIS BILL
PROVIDES A POSITIVE INCENTIVE TO
ENGAGE IN PRO BONO WORK WITHOUT
MANDATING ATTORNEYS TO DO SO.
THE LEGAL AID COMMUNITY
ACKNOWLEDGES THAT PRO BONO WORK
IS NOT THE ONLY SOLUTION TO
CALIFORNIA'S JUSTICE GAP, BUT IT
IS DEFINITELY AN ESSENTIAL PART
OF THE SOLUTION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT, ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT? PLEASE APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE. SEEING NO ONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT OPPOSITION.
LET'S TURN NOW TO THE
OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE OPPOSED TO
AB 2505, PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATORS. MY NAME IS DAVID
BULLOCK REPRESENTING THE SF
ALLIANCE, RESPECTFULLY ASKING
FOR YOUR NO VOTE. THE BILL WILL
BRING A CHILL TO LAWYERS WHO DO
NOT WISH TO DISCLOSE THEIR PRO
BONO WORK, WHO HAVE VALID
REASONS FOR NOT WANTING TO SHARE
THAT INFORMATION. THE PROPOSED
LAW SAYS THAT YOU SHALL PROVIDE
YOUR PRO BONO AND REDUCED RATE
SERVICE HOURS, MEANING THAT IS
COMPULSORY. ALTHOUGH THE BILL
DOES NOT HAVE GROUNDS FOR
DISCIPLINARY OR ADMINISTRATIVE
RECOURSE. WHAT LAWYER IS GOING
TO LIE OR OMIT INFORMATION
REQUIRED WHEN PAYING FOR THE
RENEWAL OF THEIR LICENSE TO
PRACTICE? WHEN THE INSTRUCTION
SAYS THAT YOU MUST CHARITY AND
GIVING IS A VERY PERSONAL ACT.
SOME LAWYERS MAY THRIVE ON PRO
BONO WORK, WHILE OTHERS HAD A
HORRIBLE EXPERIENCE WITH IT. OR
A PERSON MAY BE IN A POSITION
NOT TO BE ABLE TO GIVE AT THAT
TIME. CHARITY IS BEST GIVEN
BECAUSE A PERSON WANTS TO WORST
WHEN IT'S A FEELING OF
OBLIGATION. DOING SO UNDER THE
FEELING YOU SHOULD CAUSES
RESENTMENT. AND IN THIS
SITUATION, IT MAY RESULT IN A
LAWYER DOING A POOR JOB FOR
THEIR PRO BONO CLIENTS. HOW
EXACTLY IS KNOWING HOW MUCH WORK
IS DONE? PRO BONO WILL INSPIRE
OTHER WORK, OTHERS TO DO WORK
WHEN THEY'RE DOING EXACTLY THE
AMOUNT THEY WISH TO ALREADY THE
AUTHOR STATES THAT PRACTICING
LAW IS A PRIVILEGE. IT MUST BE
RECOGNIZED THAT A BAR LICENSE IS
NOT JUST GIVEN TO A LAWYER, THAT
PERSON HAD TO WORK VERY HARD AND
MAKE GREAT SACRIFICES TO ACHIEVE
THAT. LICENSES FROM THE
SCHOOLING, STUDYING IN THE
AGONIZING BAR EXAM TO CONTINUOUS
EDUCATION AND HAVING TO PAY FOR
MALPRACTICE INSURANCE. BEING A
LAWYER IS EARNED, AND IT'S A
VERY EXPENSIVE. LAWYERS MAY BE
DOING PRO BONO WORK WHERE THEY
ARE NOT COMFORTABLE REVEALING
THAT INFORMATION TO ANYWHERE
THEY MAY DO WORK. PAID FOR A
CONSERVATIVE FIRM, AND DO FREE
WORK FOR LIBERAL CAUSES, AND
DON'T WANT THEIR EMPLOYERS TO
KNOW. THE BILL DOESN'T REQUIRE
THAT YOU SAY WHERE YOU ARE DOING
THE WORK, BUT IF FOUND OUT YOU
WERE DOING X AMOUNT OF HOURS,
PEOPLE MIGHT WANT TO LOOK INTO
WHERE YOU ARE SPENDING YOUR
EXTRA TIME. THE BILL DOES STATE
THAT THE INFORMATION SHALL
REMAIN CONFIDENTIAL, BUT WE HAVE
ALL RECEIVED NOTICES SAYING THAT
OUR DATA HAS BEEN BREACHED. WHO
IS TO SAY THAT THE STATE
DATABASES WON'T BE COMPROMISED?
WILL IT EVEN BE NOTICED OR
REPORTED? IF IT IS, THERE ARE
MANY WAYS FOR DATA TO GET OUT.
THE BEST WAY OF STOPPING THIS IS
NOT TO COLLECT IT AT ALL. THANK
YOU. OTHERS IN OPPOSITION TO THE
AB 2505, SEEING NO ONE
APPROACHING QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. COMMENTS
MOTION. YES. SENATOR ALLEN,
WELL, I JUST WANT TO I, I DO
SHARE SOME OF THE CONCERNS,
RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION. IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE WAS
A AMENDMENT TAKEN. I THINK,
QUITE FRANKLY, IT WAS A VERY
IMPORTANT AMENDMENT, SUGGESTED
BY THE CALIFORNIA LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION, ALLOWING FOR FOLKS
TO SAY DECLINED TO STATE SO
THAT, SO I THINK THAT ADDRESSES
I MEAN, I UNDERSTAND, I'M SURE
GIVEN THE TENOR OF YOUR
COMMENTS, THAT YOU'D PREFER NOT
TO SEE THE BILL AT ALL, BUT THAT
THAT FOR ME WAS A REALLY
IMPORTANT, CHANGE BECAUSE I DO
AGREE THAT THIS COULD BE USED IN
MISUSE, USED IN THERE COULD BE
SOME OF THE CHILLING IMPACTS
THAT WERE RAISED BY THE, BY THE
OPPOSITION. BUT I JUST WANT TO
CONFIRM THAT, THAT, THAT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS CORRECT. SO
THERE WERE TWO AMENDMENTS TAKEN
IN THE COMMITTEE. ONE WAS AND I
THINK AN EXCELLENT SUGGESTION
THAT THE INFORMATION TO, TO
ENSURE THE CONFIDENTIALITY AND
TO HAVE A HIGHER LEVEL OF
CONFIDENTIALITY, THAT THIS
INFORMATION CAN'T BE DISCLOSED,
PURSUANT TO A PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
REQUEST. SO THAT WILL FURTHER
ENSURE THAT THERE'S
CONFIDENTIALITY AND THEN ALSO
GIVE THE STATE BAR THE
FLEXIBILITY, AS YOU MENTIONED,
SO THAT FOR FOLKS WHO DON'T WANT
TO POST, THEY'D JUST BE ABLE TO
DECLINE TO ANSWER AS, AS, AS, AS
AS, AS A WAY OF REPORTING. SO
OKAY, SO THE STATE BAR WOULD,
WOULD GIVE THE AUTHORIZATION. IT
DOESN'T IT DOESN'T PROVIDE IT AS
A, AS A REQUIRED OPTION. NO. AND
PART OF THIS IS, YOU KNOW, IN
OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM TO
PRESERVE THE APPROPRIATE AMOUNT
OF FLEXIBILITY FOR THEM TO, YOU
KNOW, ADMINISTER THIS AS THEY
WANT IT. SO IT PROVIDES IT
PROVIDES FLEXIBILITY FOR THEM TO
DO SO, BUT IT DOESN'T REQUIRE
IT. WELL, JUST JUST TO BE CLEAR,
LET ME, IF YOU DON'T MIND IF I
INTERJECT, THERE IS NO PENALTY
FOR FAILING TO RESPOND. RIGHT?
CORRECT. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
YEAH, BUT BUT BUT BUT IT'S
MANDATORY. ARE YOU ASKING ME
THAT QUESTION? ARE YOU ASKING
SOME OR GABRIEL. WELL, YEAH, IT
IS MANDATORY, BUT THERE'S NO
PENALTY FOR FAILING TO REPORT.
YEAH, BUT AS A LAWYER, I MEAN
LEGAL ETHICS, YOU KNOW, I'M
GOING TO ASK YOU, SENATOR ALLEN,
TO DIRECT YOUR QUESTION TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL. I MEAN,
LEGAL ETHICS. WOULD REQUIRE A
LAWYER, YOU KNOW, TO CARRY OUT
MANDATORY RULES OF THE STATE.
SO, YEAH, I THINK LET ME ASK A
PENALTY. I DON'T KNOW THAT
THAT'S. LET ME JUST SAY THERE'S
THE INFORMATION IS ABSOLUTELY
CONFIDENTIAL. AND WE'VE TAKEN
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION TO
PROTECT THE CONFIDENTIALITY THAT
INFORMATION, THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT. THERE'S NO PENALTY
FOR FAILING TO REPORT. AND
THERE'S ALSO NO PENALTY FOR
FAILING TO REPORT ZERO HOURS,
MAYBE JUST TO BRING US UP A
LEVEL OF GENERALITY HERE IN
TERMS OF THAT, HOPEFULLY WILL
ASSUAGE SOME OF YOUR CONCERNS.
SENATOR THIS IS WE ARE NOT
INVENTING THIS FROM SCRATCH.
CALIFORNIA IS NOT GOING TO BE
THE FIRST STATE TO DO THIS.
THERE ARE NUMEROUS RED AND BLUE
STATES THAT ARE ALREADY DOING
THIS. THEY'VE SEEN A LOT OF
SUCCESS. AS I MENTIONED, IT WAS
THE STATE OF FLORIDA FIRST DID
THIS IN 1993. SO QUITE SOME TIME
AGO. AND YOU HAVE RED STATES
LIKE INDIANA, GEORGIA, KENTUCKY,
LOUISIANA, MONTANA THAT HAVE
DONE THIS. YOU HAVE BLUE STATES
LIKE CONNECTICUT AND WASHINGTON
AND, AND, AND, AND ILLINOIS THAT
HAVE DONE THIS MARYLAND. AND I
THINK EVERYBODY HAS SEEN SUCCESS
WHO'S DONE IT. THERE HAVE NOT
BEEN A RECORD OF COMPLAINTS. AND
THAT'S WHY THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT, YOU KNOW, FOLKS ARE
PRACTITIONERS ARE ENCOURAGING
FROM HOW HAVE THOSE STATES
HANDLED THIS DECLINE TO DATE?
OPTION? BECAUSE FOR ME, WHEN I,
MAYBE I, YOU KNOW,
MISUNDERSTOOD. BUT FOR ME THAT
THAT THAT WAS A THAT WAS AN
IMPORTANT OPTION. YOU KNOW, NOT
MOST MANY PEOPLE WOULDN'T TAKE
IT, BUT THOSE WHO WANT TO FOR
THE KIND OF LEGITIMATE PRIVACY
REASONS RAISED COULD HAVE THAT
OPTION WITHOUT ANY IMMEDIATE
KIND OF OBVIOUS OPPROBRIUM. SO
HOW HAVE THEY HOW HAVE THOSE
OTHER STATES THAT YOU JUST
MENTIONED DEALT WITH THE DECLINE
TO STATE POSSIBILITY? I THINK
EACH OF THEM HAVE. I DON'T KNOW
FOR SURE. I MY, MY SENSE IS THAT
FOLKS HAVE DONE THINGS SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENTLY IN DIFFERENT STATES,
BUT I JUST THINK WE HAVEN'T, YOU
KNOW, THOSE WHO HAVE, WHAT I
WOULD CONSIDER TO BE A VERY
LIGHT TOUCH APPROACH, WHICH IS
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO REPORT THESE
HOURS WITHOUT PENALTY, WITHOUT
PENALTY, HAVE SEEN SUCCESS AND
HAVE NOT SEEN A LOT OF PROBLEMS.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF EITHER OF
THE WITNESSES WANT TO WANT TO
SPEAK TO THAT, BUT I'M NOT AWARE
OF ISSUES IN OTHER STATES WHERE
THEY HAVE ENCOURAGED FOLKS TO DO
THIS. I CAN JUST SHARE THAT.
THAT'S CORRECT. WE HAVEN'T SEEN
PROBLEMS WITH THIS IN IN OTHER
STATES. THEY'VE GENERALLY JUST
BEEN ABLE TO GET DATA THAT HAS
THEN GONE TO GOOD USE. IN FACT,
OTHER STATES OFTEN REQUIRE MORE
THAN WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR HERE.
AS ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL SAID, THIS IS A LIGHT
TOUCH. IN OTHER STATES, THEY ASK
FOR THINGS LIKE HOW MUCH MONEY
HAS BEEN DONATED TO CAUSES AND
ADDITIONAL THINGS THAT WE'RE NOT
ASKING FOR HERE WITH THIS BILL,
OKAY? I MEAN, LOOK, I'M, I'M,
YOU KNOW, WANT TO SUPPORT THE
AUTHOR. I THINK YOUR BROADER
GOALS ARE VERY MERITORIOUS. I
WOULD LIKE TO JUST PUT IN A PLUG
FOR, ENSURING THAT DECLINE TO
STATE IS A IS A REAL OPTION. I
DON'T THINK THAT MOST LAWYERS
WOULD USE IT OR WOULD WANT TO
USE IT, BUT I DO THINK THERE ARE
SOME CASES WHERE IT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT AND I JUST WOULDN'T
WANT TO SEE THE BAR, HAVE THIS
OPTION BUT NOT UTILIZE IT. AND I
THINK THERE'S A REASON WHY THE
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION BROUGHT THIS
ISSUE FORWARD, SO I JUST WANT TO
I HOPE THAT THAT THAT YOU'LL
CONSIDER AND WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO, TO ENSURE THAT
IT'S NOT JUST A, IT'S NOT JUST A
RECOMMEND, IT'S NOT JUST AN
AUTHORIZATION BUT A BUT BUT BUT
A REAL OPTION THAT'S PUT IN
FRONT OF LAWYERS. SHOULD THIS
BILL PASS? THANK YOU, SENATOR
CABALLERO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MR. CHAIR. WELL, I WANT TO, ECHO
MY CONCERNS. THE CONCERN THAT
SENATOR ALLEN RAISED AND, AND
JUST SAY THAT, ONE OF MY BIGGEST
FRUSTRATIONS HAS BEEN, WELL, ONE
OF MY BIGGEST FRUSTRATIONS IS
THAT DURING THE COVID ERA, I
COULD NOT FIND A LAWYER TO SAVE
MY LIFE. THAT WOULD DO EVICTION
DEFENSE CASES IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY, WHEN THE SITUATIONS WERE
REALLY EGREGIOUS, LANDLORDS WERE
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF, OF POOR
PEOPLE AND EVICTING THEM FOR NOT
PAYING, NOT PAYING THEIR RENT.
AND AS YOU KNOW, WE PASSED
LEGISLATION THAT PROTECTED THEM
FOR A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
TIME, AND WE PUT MONEY ON THE
TABLE AS WELL. AND WHEN WE HAD
SIGNIFICANT FLOODING IN PLANADA,
I COULDN'T FIND ANYBODY TO
REPRESENT, FARMWORKERS THAT HAD
BEEN, FLOODED ENOUGH SO THEY
LOST EVERYTHING THEY HAD IN
THEIR HOUSE, INCLUDING THEIR
VEHICLES, AND WERE WERE
UNEMPLOYED DURING THAT TIME, SO
I'M ALL FOR AND I STARTED MY
CAREER, MY LEGAL CAREER AS A
LEGAL AID LAWYER WORKING FOR
CRLA. SO FOR ME NOT TO BE ABLE
TO FIND SOMEBODY WAS JUST
REALLY, HORRENDOUS. AND SO I'M
ALL IN FAVOR OF GETTING
INFORMATION, TO MAYBE ENCOURAGE,
ATTORNEYS TO DO, PRO BONO WORK.
I MEAN, IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT IN THE COMMUNITY. TÊ.
I COULD FIND PEOPLE THAT WOULD
COME IN AND DO A KNOW YOUR LEGAL
RIGHTS, BUT THAT DOESN'T DO
ANYTHING TO HELP PEOPLE IF IN
FACT, THEY CAN'T FIND AN
ATTORNEY TO DEFEND THEM AFTER
AFTERWARDS, I'M GLAD TO HEAR
OTHER STATES HAVE FOUND THIS
METHOD TO BE SUCCESSFUL. I HAVE
MY DOUBTS. JUST I'M, JADED. I
GUESS AT THIS POINT, BUT I'M
WILLING TO GIVE IT A TRY. BUT I
DO HAVE THE SAME. THE SAME
CONCERNS. I THINK IT REALLY DOES
HAVE TO BE VOLUNTARY BECAUSE
THAT OUR OUR ETHICS TELL US YOU
HAVE TO GIVE UP INFORMATION WHEN
YOU'RE ASKED FOR IT. AND
ESPECIALLY IF IT'S A STATE BAR
WHEN YOU'RE RENEWING YOUR
LICENSE. NOBODY WANTS TO MESS
WITH THE STATE BAR, SO I THINK
THERE THERE'S A NEED TO BE ABLE
TO SAY YOU HAVE THE ABSOLUTE
RIGHT, AND SOMEWHERE ON THE FORM
IT GIVES YOU THAT RIGHT NOT TO,
EITHER IDENTIFY YOURSELF OR NOT
TO GIVE THE INFORMATION. AND SO
BUT I'M GOING TO SUPPORT YOUR
BILL TODAY. THANK YOU SENATOR.
ALL RIGHT. OTHER QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS. SEEING NO OTHER
QUESTIONS. YES. SENATOR ASHBY.
OH I'M SORRY I'LL MOVE THE BILL.
OH, SENATOR WAHAB MOVES THE BILL
ALL RIGHT, OKAY. THANK YOU.
MEMBER GABRIEL, I THINK THIS IS
A REALLY IMPORTANT BILL. I THINK
BEING A MEMBER OF PROFESSION,
AND I KNOW YOU ARE A MEMBER OF
THE PROFESSION, THAT THAT PART
OF THAT OBLIGATION IS PROVIDING
COMMUNITY SERVICE IN ONE FORM OR
ANOTHER AND REMINDING LAWYERS
THAT PRO BONO WORK IS REALLY
IMPORTANT, BOTH FOR THE
COMMUNITY AND THE PROFESSION. I
THINK THAT THIS DOES ITS JOB. I
HEARD WHAT MY COLLEAGUE SAID
FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY, SENATOR
CABALLERO, ABOUT HOW DIFFICULT
IT WAS TO FIND PRO BONO LAWYERS
DURING THE PANDEMIC. I'M HOPING
THAT THAT SHOULD WE SUFFER
ANOTHER, SIMILAR SITUATION LIKE
WE HAD DURING DURING THE
PANDEMIC, THAT THIS WILL
ACTUALLY ENCOURAGE MORE FOLKS TO
STEP UP. I IN LAST FALL, I
REPRESENTED SOMEONE IN AN
UNLAWFUL DETAINER ACTION AND IT
WAS INCREDIBLY INFORMATIVE TO ME
AS CHAIR JUDICIARY AS TO HOW
THINGS ARE WORKING OR NOT
WORKING. SO HAVING SAID THAT,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? YEAH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND I JUST
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES HERE
IN THE SENATE FOR A ROBUST
CONVERSATION. AND I KNOW, YOU
KNOW, I REMEMBER ACTUALLY,
SENATOR ALLEN BEING A YOUNG
ATTORNEY AND TALKING TO YOU WHEN
YOU WERE JUST A SLIGHTLY OLDER
ATTORNEY ABOUT SOME OF THE VERY
MEANINGFUL EXPERIENCES THAT YOU
HAD IN DOING PRO BONO. AND I
KNOW, SENATOR CABALLERO, WE LOOK
WITH A LOT OF ADMIRATION ABOUT
HOW YOU STARTED YOUR CAREER
DOING LEGAL SERVICES AND HOW
IMPORTANT THOSE ARE. AND I WILL
TAKE THIS FEEDBACK VERY
SERIOUSLY, IF IT DOES HELP TO
ASSUAGE SOME OF THE CONCERNS, WE
HAVE ACTUALLY CONSULTED WITH
MANY NATIONAL LAW FIRMS THAT
HAVE FOLKS IN A LOT OF STATES
WHERE THIS IS ALREADY REQUIRED,
WHO ARE IN SUPPORT PART OF THIS
MEASURE, YOU KNOW, AND YOU CAN
SEE LETTERS FROM NATIONAL FIRMS
LIKE ORRICK, HERRINGTON AND
SUTCLIFFE AND OTHERS WHO HAVE
THOUGHT THAT THIS TO BE A GOOD
IDEA. YOU KNOW, TALK TO SENATOR
ALLEN WITH DAVID LASH AT
O'MELVENY AND MYERS AS WE WERE
STRUCTURING THIS BILL. SO
THERE'S A LOT OF FOLKS WHO HAVE
SEEN THIS WORK IN OTHER STATES
AND WHO THINK IT WOULD BE A
HELPFUL THING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND I GUESS I'LL
JUST CLOSE WITH WHAT SENATOR
UMBERG SAYS IN QUOTE FROM THE
EXECUTIVE SUMMARY OF THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE REPORT,
WHICH SAYS THAT EXISTING LAW
PROVIDES THAT EVERY LAWYER
AUTHORIZED AND PRIVILEGED TO
PRACTICE LAW IN THE STATE IS
EXPECTED TO PROVIDE VOLUNTARY,
PRO BONO LEGAL SERVICES TO THOSE
WHO CANNOT AFFORD THE HELP OF A
LAWYER. SO THIS IS PART OF THE
OBLIGATION THAT WE TAKE ON. IT'S
PART OF THE EXPECTATION WHEN WE
GET A BAR CARD. SO I DON'T THINK
FOLKS WILL BE SURPRISED. BUT I
DO THINK YOU HAVE RAISED SOME
POINTS FOR US TO CONSIDER AND WE
PROMISE TO CONSIDER THEM. AND
WITH THAT WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MADAM SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB 2505.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BY UMBERG I WILK NÓ WILK NÓ
ALLEN. ALLEN I ASHBY. ASHBY I
COPY, COPY I RUSSELL GRASSO I
LAYERED LAYERED I NILO ROTH.
STERN STERN I WAHAB WAHAB I. 8
TO 1 EIGHT ONE. WE'RE GOING TO
PUT THAT ON CALL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
NEXT, CHAIR KALRA, THIS IS OUR
LAST BILL TODAY. I KNOW THAT
SOUNDS AMAZING, THIS IS OUR LAST
BILL TODAY, SO IT SOUNDS BETTER
FOR YOU. ALL RIGHT, SO I
ENCOURAGE, I THINK WE'RE SHORT
ONE MEMBER. THAT AFTER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARO PRESENTS HIS BILL
AND ASSUMING A VOTE IS TAKEN,
THAT THAT WE WILL LIFT CALLS. SO
OKAY. AND WE'LL DO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AFTER THIS BILL. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR, ASSEMBLY BILL 3283 IS A
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. BILL ON
CLAIMS OF EXEMPTION. THIS BILL
PROPOSES A MINOR PROCEDURAL FIX
TO A CRITICAL ISSUE IN DEBT
COLLECTION CASES. UNDER EXISTING
LAW, WHEN A DEBTOR APPEARS IN
COURT TO FILE A CLAIM OF
EXEMPTION, ESSENTIALLY SEEKING
PROTECTION FOR CERTAIN ASSETS
FROM BEING COLLECTED TO PAY A
JUDGMENT IS CONSIDERED A GENERAL
APPEARANCE. THIS SEEMINGLY SMALL
ACT, HOWEVER, HAS SIGNIFICANT
CONSEQUENCES BY MERELY SHOWING
UP TO PROTECT THEIR EXEMPT
PROPERTY, DEBTORS
UNINTENTIONALLY SURRENDER THEIR
ABILITY TO CHALLENGE THE COURT'S
JURISDICTION IN THE UNDERLYING
DEBT COLLECTION CASE, EVEN IF
THEY WERE IMPROPERLY SERVED OR
ARE NOT THE CORRECT PARTY. THIS
BILL OFFERS A SIMPLE YET CRUCIAL
SOLUTION TO THIS UNFAIR
SITUATION. IT ENSURES THAT
APPEARING FOR A CLAIM OF
EXEMPTION HEARING DOES NOT
EQUATE TO CONSENTING TO THE
COURT'S JURISDICTION FOR THE
ENTIRE CASE. INSTEAD, THIS BILL
WOULD LIMIT THE COURT'S
AUTHORITY SOLELY TO DETERMINING
THE CLAIM OF EXEMPTION. THIS
MEANS THAT DEBTORS CAN STILL
SEEK EXEMPTION FROM COLLECTION
WITHOUT FORFEIT, THEIR RIGHT TO
CHALLENGE THE VALIDITY OF THE
UNDERLYING JUDGMENT BASED ON
JURISDICTIONAL ISSUES. THIS BILL
DOES NOT ELIMINATE LAWFUL DEBTS.
RATHER, IT PROTECTS THE
FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLE OF DUE
PROCESS BY ALLOWING DEBTORS TO
CHALLENGE THE COURT'S
JURISDICTION IF THEY WERE
IMPROPERLY SERVED OR MISTAKENLY
IDENTIFIED. BY SAFEGUARDING THIS
RIGHT, WE AIM TO PREVENT UNJUST
JUDGMENTS AND ENSURE FAIRNESS IN
OUR LEGAL SYSTEM. I HAVE WITH ME
DESIREE NGUYEN AUTH, THE
DIRECTOR OF THE EAST BAY
COMMUNITY LAW CENTER'S CONSUMER
JUSTICE CLINIC, TO TESTIFY AND
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
GOOD AFTERNOON. OH. I'M SORRY.
GO AHEAD. FLOOR IS YOURS. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I'M DESIREE NGUYEN
AUTH, DIRECTOR OF THE CONSUMER
JUSTICE PRACTICE AT EAST BAY
COMMUNITY LAW CENTER AND
LECTURER AT BERKELEY LAW. AB
3283 IS A NONPARTISAN CORRECTION
TO THE CODE OF CIVIL PROCEDURE
AS IT IS CURRENTLY WRITTEN
SECTION 703.5580. THE CLAIM OF
EXEMPTION CONSTITUTES THE
PLEADINGS SUBJECT TO THE POWER
OF THE COURT, TO PERMIT
AMENDMENTS IN THE INTEREST OF
JUSTICE. THIS TRAMPLES THE BASIC
DUE PROCESS RIGHTS OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE NOT PROPERLY SERVED, AND
FIND THEMSELVES TO BE THE
SUBJECT OF ENFORCEMENT THROUGH A
DEFAULT JUDGMENT. AT THIS
JUNCTURE, A CLAIMANT HAS TWO
OPTIONS EITHER A FOREGO A CLAIM
OF EXEMPTION AND BEAR THE BURDEN
OF ENFORCEMENT WHILE SEEKING TO
SET ASIDE OR B FORFEIT THEIR
RIGHT TO DUE PROCESS IN ORDER TO
STOP THE BLEEDING OF THE ILL
GOTTEN JUDGMENT BY PROCEEDING
WITH A NECESSARY CLAIM OF
EXEMPTION. UNDER THE FIRST
OPTION, A PERSON MUST BE ABLE TO
LIVE UNDER A WAGE GARNISHMENT OR
BANK LEVY. ENFORCEMENT. FOR
SEVERAL MONTHS, THE FILING
PROCEDURES TO HAVE A MOTION
HEARD VARIES FROM COUNTY TO
COUNTY, WITH MANY HAVING
OPENINGS NOT EARLIER THAN THREE
MONTHS OUT. THIS IS INCREDIBLY
LONG FOR PEOPLE WHO LIVE
PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK. IN THIS
SITUATION, THE PERSON IS
SUBSIDIZING THE STATE WHEN THEY
PURSUE THEIR DUE PROCESS RIGHTS.
UNDER THE SECOND OPTION, A
PERSON SURRENDERS THEIR RIGHT TO
PROPER SERVICE IN THE NAME OF
CAUTERIZING A FINANCIAL WOUND.
IN DOING SO, THE PERSON GIVES UP
THEIR RIGHTS TO SET ASIDE USING
A SPECIAL APPEARANCE AND THE
ISSUE IS MADE MOOT BECAUSE THE
CURRENT LANGUAGE IS EXPLICIT
ABOUT THE TREATMENT OF THE CLAIM
OF EXEMPTION AS A PLEADING.
BEFORE I ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
TODAY, I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS SOME
COMMON MISCONCEPTIONS. WILL THIS
BILL INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE TO
IGNORE SERVICE OR DODGE SERVICE?
NO THIS BILL DOES NOT CHANGE THE
STATUS OF JURISDICTION ON A
PERSON WHO IS PROPERLY SERVED.
PROPERLY SERVED INCLUDES
SUBSTITUTE SERVICE, SO THE
COLLOQUIAL DODGING IS NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE. THE CHANGE THAT WE
SEEK ONLY LETS THROUGH THE FISH
THAT SHOULD NOT BE IN THE NET IN
THE FIRST PLACE. IT DOES NOTHING
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE PROPERLY
UNDER THE JURISDICTION OF THE
COURT. ADDITIONALLY, THERE WILL
BE BAD ACTORS IN NEARLY ALL
AVENUES WHERE IT IS POSSIBLE TO
EVADE THE LAW. THIS MINORITY IS
NOT A VALID REASON TO CONTINUE
TO DENY DUE PROCESS RIGHTS TO
THE MAJORITY OF PEOPLE IN THE
SYSTEM. IF ANYTHING, THE CURRENT
LAW INCENTIVIZES THE RAMPANT
SEWER SERVICE THAT WE SEE TODAY
AND IT IS A WINDFALL FOR MANY
PLAINTIFFS. TWO WHY DON'T PEOPLE
JUST GET A SET ASIDE? GO AHEAD
AND WRAP IT UP. YES TO GET US
SET ASIDE REQUIRES A LOT OF
LEGAL KNOW HOW. IT IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT I COULD EVER
ADVISE A CLIENT TO DO THEMSELVES
. IT TAKES MONTHS TO GO THROUGH
THE PROCESS, THEN HAVE A MOTION
HEARD ALL WHILE THE MONEY IS
DRAINING FROM A PERSON'S POCKET.
ALL RIGHTY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. OKAY.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS DANA DE
BèC FROM EBCLC IN BERKELEY. LAW
AND I SUPPORT THANK YOU OTHERS
IN SUPPORT. NANDITA RAGHAVAN ON
BEHALF OF EAST BAY COMMUNITY LAW
CENTER, I SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT. SEEING NO ONE
ELSE APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE.
THOSE WHO ARE OPPOSED PLEASE
APPROACH IF YOU'RE OPPOSED TO, A
B. 3283 SEEING NO ONE APPROACHES
THE MICROPHONE, LET'S BRING IT
BACK. COMMITTEE. COMMITTEE
MEMBER QUESTIONS? YES, SENATOR
WAHAB, SENATOR WAHAB HAS MOVED
THE BILL SEEING NO OTHER
QUESTIONS. SOME. MR. CHAIR,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
RESPECTFULLY ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ALRIGHTY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM SECRETARY.
IF YOU WOULD CALL THE ROLL, THIS
IS FILE ITEM NUMBER 12 AB 3283.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS UMBERG.
AYE UMBERG. AYE. WILK. NÓ. WILK.
NO. ALLEN ALLEN. AYE. ASHBY.
ASHBY. AYE. CABALLERO CABALLERO.
AYE. DURAZZO. DURAZZO. AYE
LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE. NILO. NO.
NILO NO. ROTH. STERN. STERN. AYE
WAHAB. AYE. WAHAB. AYE 8 TO 2
WITH ONE MEMBER MISSING TO TWO.
WE'RE GOING TO PUT THAT ON CALL
HERE FOR A LITTLE BIT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MR. CHAIR, ALL RIGHT,
WE'VE HEARD ALL THE BILLS. LET'S
LET'S DO THIS. LET'S WAIT
ANOTHER. I HEAR THE DOOR OPENING
. WE NEED TO CONSENT. AND FILE
ITEM THREE. YES. ALL RIGHT,
LET'S DO THIS. LET'S DO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR, WHO ARE WE
MISSING, SENATOR ROTH? OKAY. ALL
RIGHT, LET'S DO, LET'S LET'S DO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. IS THERE.
SENATOR LAIRD IS MOVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ALL RIGHT,
MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. BURKE.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WILK. AYE
WILK. AYE. ALLEN. ALLEN. AYE.
ASHBY ASHBY. AYE. CABALLERO.
CABALLERO. AYE. DURAZZO DURAZZO.
AYE. LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE NILO.
NILO. AYE. ROTH. STERN A STERN.
AYE. WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE. 10 TO 0
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR TEN
ZERO. WE'RE GOING TO PUT THAT ON
CALL. ALL RIGHT, LET'S GO TO
ITEM NUMBER THREE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES. SENATOR LAIRD
HAS MOVED THE BILL. MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE,
AB 1899. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS UMBERG
I UMBERG I WILK NÓ. WILK. NÓ.
ALLEN. ALLEN. AYE. ASHBY ASHBY.
AYE. CABALLERO CABALLERO. AYE.
RUSSELL Tð. RUSSELL. AYE. LAIRD.
LAIRD. AYE. NILO NILO. NØ. ROTH.
STERN A STERN. AYE. WAHAB.
WAHAB. AYE 8 TO 2. EIGHT TWO.
WE'RE GOING TO PUT THAT ON CALL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX AB 2801.
CHAIR VOTING AYE. NILO NÓ. NILO
NÓ ROTH. STERN AN A STERN AYE.
WAHAB WAHAB. AYE. 8 TO 2 ONE
MEMBER MISSING EIGHT TWO. WE'LL
PUT THAT ON CALL. FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT AB 2505. CHAIR
VOTING AYE. NILO NILO NÓ ROTH 8
TO 2 ONE MEMBER MISSING STILL
EIGHT TWO. WE'LL PUT THAT ON
CALL. AND THE LAST ONE IS STILL
ALL RIGHT. SO WE'RE GOING TO
RECESS HERE FOR A FEW MOMENTS,
FOR OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
APPEAR.
NOW WE'RE GOING TO LIFT CALLS ON
ALL THE BILLS. ALL RIGHT, MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. CHAIR
VOTING AYE. ROTH. ROTH. AYE. 11
TO 0 ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. 11
ZERO. THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED. FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE,
AB 1899. CHAIR VOTING AYE. ROTH
ROTH. AYE. 9 TO 2 NINE TWO.
BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX
AB 2801. CHAIR VOTING AYE. ROTH
ROTH. AYE 9 TO 2 NINE TWO. BILLS
OUT. FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB
2505. CHAIR VOTING AYE. ROTH.
ROTH. AYE 9 TO 2 NINE TWO. BILLS
OUT AND FILE ITEM NUMBER 12 AB
3283. CHAIR VOTING AYE. ROTH
ROTH. AYE 9 TO 2. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU,
SENATOR ROTH. THAT CONCLUDES THE
BILLS OUT O THE BILL IS OUT OKAY
. THANK YOU. THERE WE GO, THAT
CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS TODAY. WE
WILL RECONVENE NEXT TUESDAY AT
130. YES. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU ALL.